bébé de dos sandra cherchant
illustration cécile que du beau
souraya édition un beau matin d'été le
coq se met à chanter plus tôt que
d'habitude
réveillez-vous réveillez-vous savoir
retenti dans tout le village pour
alerter les habitants
poilant bataille plus en désordre les
animaux se dirige vers un immense
flamboyant où les attend nous vous le
paille-en-queue cardinal bélier pétrels
martin cectek l'endormi tortue tous
répondent présents à l'appel du gop
regarder d'une chat le loup est vêtu de
bleu quelque chose d'important est
arrivé at on nous propose quelques
villageois
au même moment ils aperçoivent deux
dodos qui pleure à chaudes larmes
surpris ils se rassemblent autour d'eux
que se passe-t-il demande le martin
pourquoi purée vous questionne le
cardinal mais le chagrin leur cloue le
bec en tant que chef du village
nous nous répond à leur place le bébé de
me raser ma rue a disparu partons vite
sa recherche
un vent de panique commence à souffler
sur le village où est le petit coquin
dans un pape aille au milieu des
bougainvillées sous une fleur d'hibiscus
même les tortues les l'endormi perdent
leur calme et se lance dans une
véritable exploration de la végétation
mais
rien en vue pas même un oeuf de lézard
au milieu de cette agitation résonne
sous d'un étrange musique est tournée
tout se rapproche
abandonnant leurs recherches et découvre
ainsi que le musicien n'est autre que me
connaît tout le vieux temps au milieu
d'une ronde de curieux il prend la
parole
marmaille je sais où se trouve bébé de
dos cette nuit un pape en l'emmener dans
son repère en haut de la montagne du
camp la montagne vous quand ces trois
mots font battre les coeurs plus fort qu
un djembé boum boum boum
car c'est là-bas que vit la sorcière
celle qui grognent si fort que tout le
village en tremblent la voix de me
connaît toutes les ramène à la terrible
réalité qui va aller chercher bébé de
dos demande lesage rapidement tous les
regards se tournent vers mario qui comme
ses dalons ne s'est jamais aventuré hors
du village
la peur au ventre le malheureux demande
qui veut ma compagne et c'est beaucoup
trop loin et pour le bélier tu vas te
perdre en chemin
répond le tec tec timmy et un lander qui
a aussi s'enfuir en joie de tristesse
intervient il ne m'est rien arrivé
lorsque je suis parti et je n'ai pas vu
la sorcière
tu ne peux pas laisser tomber b là bas
tu dois aller le chercher
le coeur en lambeaux papa de dos ne sait
plus quoi faire
ira-t-il on ira t'il pas finalement le
voilà parti en se dandinant comme un
doux
avec un soleil de plomb pour seul
compagnon
de plus en plus en âge son corps
s'épuisent au fil des paysages sur un
chemin bordé de jacarandas et de cities
parmi les plus belles fleurs
mario ne parvint pas oublié ses valeurs
car au bout du chemin coule une rivière
malgré sa forte envie de reculer il
prend son courage à deux pattes et
avance dans l'eau glacée un pas deux pas
trois pas trop malheureux il finit par
perdre l'équilibré
le voilà à l'eau pendant sa chute son
bâton offert par me connaît tout tous
une fleur de nénuphars sous ses yeux et
merveilleux lafleur se mettent à grossir
grossir au point de devenir gigantesque
l'oiseau s'installe au milieu des
pétales heureux d'avoir trouvé une
barque plume au vent il se laisse
emporter par les courants et parvint
jusqu'à l'autre rive où un autre défi
l'attend face à lui se dresse une forêt
plus noir que la nuit dans cette
obscurité totale le moindre murmure lui
donne des frissons
jusqu'au moment où des rayons de lumière
s'échappe de son baluchon souvient-il
mario dfl ne et voit la papaye qui
scintille telle une grosse pierre
précieuse
cueillies dans le jardin de me connaît
tout elle devait lui servir de repas il
ouvre le fruit d'où s'envolent alors des
papillons aux couleurs chatoyantes bleu
lagon rose bonbon rouge vermillon leurs
ailes brillant de mille feux et claire
la forêt d'où s'élèvent
chanson c'est nous nos allons te montrer
le chemin
le 2-2 s'empresse d'accepter
l'invitation et aperçoit dans le
lointain la montagne boucan qui se
dessine enfin alors que le brave
commence à gravir la pente résonne bruit
plus terrifiant que le tonnerre peuvent
peuvent ce bruit provoquent le départ de
tous les papes en raffolent et pourquoi
fuyez vous demande mario filant la
vitesse de l'éclair
les oiseaux lui jette à peine un regard
c'est sûrement la sorcière se dit il de
plus en plus inquiet pourquoi est elle
si en colère
et toute cette fumée dans le ciel que
fait elle me jeter dans sa marmite
persuadé que son bébé est en danger il
voudra le sauvé mais restent figées trop
impressionné par ce qu'il voit jamais
mariona système pareil spectacle tels
des pétales de flamboyant qui danse dans
le vent la lave jaillit
puis elle ruisselle sur les flancs du
piton tous ces bruits effrayants de le
village n'était que ceux d'un volcan un
soupir de soulagement poussé papa de
doha perçoit à présent un oeuf qui vogue
tranquillement sur une coulée de lave
l'amour rempli son coeur se répandant
c'est elle qui se déploie enfin en plein
vol et saisi l'oeuf puis le sert très
fort en murmurant mon bébé enfin je t'ai
retrouver un beau matin d'été le coq se
met à chanter plus tôt que d'habitude
réveillez-vous réveillez-vous savoir
retenti dans tout le village
pour alerter les habitants poil sans
bataille plus en désordre les animaux se
dirige vers un immense ce flamboyant où
les attend loulou le paille-en-queue
cardinal bélier pétrels mardaing tec tec
l'endormi tortue tous répondent présents
à l'appel du coq
regardez du le ch a loué vêtus de bleu
quelque chose d'important est arrivé à
tous nous propose quelques villageois
au même moment ils aperçoivent deux
dodos qui sourit en tenant un neuf
l'aco qui se fissure apparaît alors un
magnifique bébé de dos